.
WEK O THEY'VAKE
INCREDI
TO "THLEPER.D
LEAD.
THE WHITE HOUSE THTHM AFGHISN A
LI ITS GRI
ON THAT COUNTRY, AND
EVACUATE.TO SAFELY
THIS AFTERON
TAREED TO GIVE LLIVAN SA
CIVILIANS SAFE PASGEO THKABUL OR
MILITARY IS HOPING TO SPEE THE
DEFENSE ONOW
NS
THEY WERE SAFELY ON
SUNDAY TO E WHITE HOUSE ESTI
AT LEAST000 AMERICANMAIN AFGHAN.
BUT THOSFIGURELUDETENS OF THOUSA
ALLIES WPED THE S.
UT OF THE MILIES, WHO CO K THEY
GHAN CAPGE
KAL.YOU'RE GETTING OF JUST W QUI
WHO ARE
THE NENDHES OF NORMALCY CREEPINB
ONTO THE KREETS.NOUNCE
GOVERNMENT WORKERS SHOULD BE
RETURNING TO THEIRTODA TICEMEN
ON THE ROADS GUIDING TRAFFIC
THE TALIBAN REALLY WANTS TO SHOW
FORCE, THAT IT CAN EFFECVERN.
BU IMPOSSIBLOR WERT AS WEN
WHILE WALKING AROUHE
STREET
AND WE WENE
HEAR THR STOR
TAKE A
PEOPLE WERE BACK ON THREETS,AN
PEOPLE.SIBLE NOT TO NOTICTHAT
LARGELY MELTED A
ORE WA
BUSINESS THAN USMO TA DECADE MO
HAS ENUR
HEAD TO TOE COVERINGS ON THE TA.
IN BURQAS RIGHT NOW?lator: BECAE
AFRAID SS WHY THEY'RE AL
G BUNED?.
FIRSTHAND.WAS T DOWNTOWN, WE
THAT HEREASHW S PETRIFIED
ORGANIZATIONS AND SAYS SHEHASN'
EXACTLYS NOT EASY FOR PERSON T
HAVE WORKE
O,OT ANGRYBU A TH YO A MORE THA
I NEED THEIRorIO WELL.
>> YCAUSE I'M THINUT MY TURE, GY
KILL ME,RS WIT MOTHER?
>> Reporter: THE TALIBAN SAYS
AVE LEARNED FROM HISTORY
AND THAT WOMEN'S RIGHTS WILL BE
PROTECTED.
BUT MANYULN WOMEN
UR T
A FE
THAT THERE ARE
TALIBA OUTSIDEER
FRDO I
GO IALONE.
THIS WOM ONE OE AFGHAN
VENTOTIATORS D
PEACE TALKS WI THET WITHHEOTE S
IS NOT ENOUGH.
O ISSUTS, BU ONCCRAFGHANTA HAVEM
>> Reporter: SHE HAS
ASON NOTUST.
R SHE WASH B
UNN GUNMEN.
TH
>>? ARE YOU YOU HAVE CHILDREN.>R
AFANI DON' TCONCERNED FORY S ANF
ITSELF ON THEM
THT TIME IN  FROM
THE TALIBAN SPPE
.A PRESS COEN
D IT WAS RIN
THPES OF QUESTIONS THAT
WERE ASKED BGHTS
ITSHOW
MUCH CHANGED HER NETI
THESE JOURNALISTS WERE NOT
PUTHEY PUSHED HIM ON WENRIGHTS.
THEY PUSHED HIM ON WHETHER WOMEN
WORKING  JOURNALISTS, CONTINUEON
AND HE WAS SORT OFGLING AN GIV
HE
BUT THE ONE QUESTIONTUCK WITH ,
HE WAS TALKIS
BLANKET NE THEHAS GRANTED TOVER.
AND THISSTOOD
SAYS, BUT WILL THEHA
THE INNOCEIVILIANS
TO WHICH HAP WELL,
THAT'SLAGE
HAENTHE COURAGE HA TO ASK THATU,
TO LOOK HIM SQUARE I
AND ASK IT SPEAKS
TO THE REAL CHANGES TH H
HAPPENED HERE HE20
YEARS, JAKE.AND WHETHER THE TAL
CH, THE PEOPLE HERE CEIS
WHOLE GENERATION OF GIRLS, ANDDE
INASRS.
CLARISSA, WHAT WAS THED LIKE
WHEN YOU WERE WALKING
L EARLIETODAY?
FEELS .rter:RY STRAN
FEERE ISN'T THAT SAM AJOURNALIRI
UP.AND THAT'STIECAUSE OF
THOPNE
THO
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN E
BUT THE MARKET WAS BUSTLING.
T A THIRD OF THE
STORES, IF NOT HALF OF
STORES, WERE OPEN.AND TRAFFIC W.
THIS IS THISE TALIBA HAVE TO GET
THEY KNOW THAT THAG AGAIN.
THAT IF THERE IS ANYF VIOLENT OF
LOSE THE MOMENTUM THAT THEY HAV
THEY'RE BENEVOLENT AS WELL AS
ABLE TO PROVIDE LAW ANU HEARD IO
WOMEN, AND PARTICULARLY FROM
FAAORDINARILY
POLITICIAN.
THE PRF IN THE
WE'VE SEEN TALIBAN YOU DO.
THEY TOOK OV THE COURY
BI GIRLS FORCING NTO ON'T WANT
MARRS, FORCING
TALIBAMEDAY THAT  WITHON T
THEY'VE PLY TO
VIOLENCECAN ANYBODY TRUST AN TH?
Reporr: THINK THAT FOR
REALLY HARD TIME TRUSTING.
AND I ASKE ID YOALWIOU'V
WITHHEM, YOU'VE NE  DO YOLI
SHE SAID FOR NOW IT'FOR ME TO T
ENTIRELY.
RE'S T, JAKE.
IT'S NOT ENOUGR THN  TO SAN CAN
IT'S ABOUT LEADING BY EXAMPLE.
AND SO IN WANTALLY KNOW THAT THN
TH ACTIVELY CAMPAIGN
FOKEIT CLEAR TO ALL THE PEOPLEN
THIS THAIS A NEWRECTIOE E R WOM
ZO, SHE
TOLD MTH HER SISTER WENT OUT
ANE GROCER AT THE GROCERY
PR COVERING.HE NEVER WOULD'VE I
WEEKS AGO.
BUT NOW BECAUSE THE TALIBAN IS
IN TOWN, PEOPLE ADOP
POSTURE.
THEY CHANGE THEIR BEVIEASE WHAT
F  RULER
HERE. PROBLEM
N PATALIBAN CAN'T JUST SAY
THEY HAVE TOY SHOW BAMBEEN
THEY'RE GOING TON.D I WOULD SAY
FAITH THAT TH
IS HAPPEN.
>> CLARISSA WARD LIVE IN KABUL,
GHN, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
NOW TSCE
FORMER COMMANDER OF U.S. NATO I
TO01NERAL, I'D LIKE TO
UR REACTION HA T WE'VE SEEN OUT
TO OBSERVET IT'ST
'S TAN YOU MAY THINKF
THE PREVIOUSN GOVERNMENTPL GROUP
G AGAINST  KILLECIS LEFTND THINR
GETTING TO KABUL, IT'S VT AS